he went with training legs and with
Fandango has dr. nice talk to you so I
know a lot of fans are probably
wondering where in the heck is Chris
Redfield hiding no now we yeah that's a
good question
I guess he was there from the beginning
in the video games but they waited until
now to introduce him and the in the
franchise and I think he gets a really
nice debut now does he kick some ass in
this I mean you know in the last couple
we see the ladies kicking some butt so
I'm wonder if the guys are gonna kind of
catch up here now the ladies continue to
kick butt which is as it should be
Amelia Zahra Ripley I like to say but
Chris definitely holds his own
absolutely now I heard you talking about
some of the stunts that you've done in
this film would you say that the the
Prison Break you know serious kind of
prepared you for what you had to do in
this film yeah there's a lot of running
and jumping and fighting and the Antan
combat in Prison Break and it was great
training for something like this the
difference of course is that you know we
shot this movie in 3d and the new
technology brings with it a different
level of challenges because it's a lot
easier to to tell when the actors are
faking it if you're not making contact
with someone's face with your fists
the cameras can kind of see around
corners and they get that so you have to
bump up your game a little bit as far as
selling these sequences to the audience
sounds like it opens the door for much
more injury potentially but we
approached it in like the safest way
possible and ever if ever in the middle
of a sequence someone felt that they
were suddenly off in their timing or
they forgot what the next move was or
where the next punch was coming from you
know they said stop and everyone took a
break so no injuries did you prepare
yourself in any way as far as training
of some sort of martial arts in getting
ready for this film no it was more about
getting ready in terms of stamina I just
wanted to be able to execute the stunts
myself as much as possible and bring my
a-game to the table now is this your
first time at comic-con it is and and
have you had a chance to at least relish
of what's what's going on here only
seeing the crowds outside I haven't had
a chance to get out on the floor yet but
I've I've been told it's got a
particular kind of
yet I should definitely experience
before I go so I'm gonna make sure that
happens
congratulations on the film thanks for
the time